bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
avec aujourd'hui une question la
bourgogne doit-elle accueillir des
migrants au moment où le gouvernement
s'apprête à démanteler la jungle de
calais deux invités pour en débattre le
député de l'yonne guillaume larrivé
bonjour bonjour guillaume larrivé vous
êtes un des porte parole du parti les
républicains et le sénateur socialiste
de la nièvre gaëtan gorce bonjour mon
jeu vous avez récemment rendu au sénat
avec jacques gendre un rapport sur le
sujet un sujet qui divise énormément
nous avons pu le mesurer avec un très
grand nombre de réactions que vous avez
posté sur les réseaux sociaux en réponse
à notre question des réactions qui ont
et c'était une forme de surprises
répondu majoritairement oui il faut
accueillir des migrants alors bien sûr
ça n'a aucune valeur de sondage mais ça
va nous donner un point de départ pour
ce débat on a entendu une partie de la
droite et de l'extrême droite s'opposer
à la volonté de l'état d'installer des
migrants de calais dans toute la france
mais il ya aussi une réalité différente
avec un certain nombre de centres qui
existe déjà en france dès qu'on appelle
des cada dessau
il ya eu le chiffre de 1000 mais rossi
qui ont proposé des locaux dans le pays
alors kit est ce qu on tord la réalité
dans cette affaire guillaume larrivé est
ce que finalement l'opposition n'est pas
si forte que ça ou est-ce que de votre
point de vue elle est très forte je
pense qu'il faut éviter les débats
caricaturaux les polémiques inutiles et
garder à l'esprit une idée très simple
c'est que au delà des chiffres
au delà des réalités quantitative on
parle de personnes et ce qui doit nous
guider
je crois dans cette affaire c'est une
notion très très simple c'est la notion
de respect respect de ces personnes
immigrées respect aussi de la france et
des français et je crois que la vraie
question à se poser c'est est-ce que la
france aujourd'hui a les capacités
d'accueil les capacités d'intégration
les besoins aussi économique pour
accueillir plus ou pas plus d'immigrés
tout en restant fidèles à nos principes
notamment nos principes d'accueil des
réfugiés politiques des personnes
persécutées
c'est ça la vraie question de fond et
ensuite je crois que c'est une question
de curseur le respect le respect aussi
des communautés
villageoise des communes des volontés
locales les capacités locales
je pense qu'il faut sortir des
caricatures âgées entre laurent wauquiez
dit jeffrey au soutien tous les maires
qui ne voudront pas de migrants chez eux
sk par une forme d'utilisation politique
du sujet il ya en tout cas une réalité
c'est que la france accueille chaque
année des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de personnes étrangères
d'immigrés sous divers statuts on pourra
revenir en détail
donc on n'est pas du tout aujourd'hui en
france dans l'immigration zéro
on aa à prendre en compte une donnée
géopolitique et économique aussi qui est
nouvelle je crois qu'il faut le faire
avec intelligence avec mesure s'agit pas
d' accueillir tout le monde
il s'agit pas non plus de refuser
d'accueillir un certain nombre de
personnes persécutées qui sont des vrais
réfugiés des vrais combattants de la
liberté pour vendre ensuite dans des
détails mais aussi pour la position
équilibrée jeu pas pour une position
caricaturale extrémistes dans un sens ou
dans l'autre je suis pour qu'on soit
assez fermé on va choisir naturel même
entendu un certain nombre de positions
assez caricatural gaëtan gorce vous
aviez dit c'était sur notre antenne au
moment où certains parler de mini jungle
de calais en parlant de l'ouverture de
centrales et disney pas s'il y aura
beaucoup de mini jungles mais je
pressens que j'ai eu le sentiment mais
je suis rassurée en écoutant ses
premiers propos que l'on cherchait à à
utiliser ces événements qui sont
dramatiques ces situations qui sont
épouvantables sur le plan humain mais
qu'ils sont c'est d'ailleurs sur le plan
de politique et militaire pour faire de
la politique intérieure ce qui après
tout est des choses auxquelles on
assiste parfois mais qui était très
chaud quand on regarde la réalité parce
que la situation dans lequel dans
laquelle nous sommes est de savoir si
nous accordons ou non notre assistance à
des personnes qui sont en danger c'est
un sos que la plupart 12 ans il faut
savoir de quoi on parle notamment
latence à mélanger les choses la
première chose si on veut avoir un débat
clair et donc se respecter c'est de bien
distinguer les sujets il ya un premier
sujet celui qui a été provoquée par la
grande crise migratoire de cette année
de l'an passé qui est celui des réfugiés
sur ceux qui quittent leur pays l'irak
le pakistan l'afghanistan la syrie pour
particulièrement parce qu'il a moins ils
sont en danger et en danger de mort cela
on a le devoir de les accueillir
c'est la loi internationale c'est notre
constitution j'allais presque dire c'est
un devoir
dit et auquel nous sommes les uns les
autres j'espère attaché beaucoup de ces
réfugiés sont à calais la situation est
très varié évidemment mais beaucoup de
ces réfugiés sont à calais pourrions
nous laisser à calais les personnes dont
les situations elle se trouve je suis
allé personnellement à calais j'ai
visité le camp je ne suis pas allée avec
la presse les médias ni un responsable
politique je me suis contenté de visiter
et de rencontres et de parler avec les
personnes qui s'y trouvaient la détresse
le désarroi le malheur la misère de ces
personnes ce qu'ils ont vécu pour
arriver jusque-là nécessite évidemment
de la part de la république si elle veut
rester fidèle à ses valeurs on parler de
respect si elle veut contrer le respect
des principes qu'elle agisse on ne
pouvait pas laisser ces personnes dans
cette situation est donc tenté de les
répartir sur le territoire français avec
toutes les difficultés ça peut
représenter avec le respect qu'on doit
évidemment aux élus et aux habitants
était une nécessité on pouvait pas
continuer à tolérer une situation est
pourtant ce qu on entend presque
systématiquement ses on veut ouvrir un
centre pour 20 personnes dans un petit
village mais on va en prendre tout de
suite des gens dire oui tout le monde
dit il faut respecter les êtres humains
mais pas chez nous alors je remercie
gaëtan gorce d'introduire le débat de
manière en effet rationnelle restons sur
cette question ces personnes dont gaëtan
gorce parler son talent des réfugiés
politiques au sens juridique du terme
où sont elles des personnes qui
demandent à être reconnus comme réfugiés
politiques il ya il ya plus qu'une
nuance
parce que la nuance c'est quoi c'est la
différence entre des personnes qui sont
des vrais combattants de la liberté qui
ont vocation à devenir des réfugiés
politiques avec une carte de séjour
délivré par la république française vrai
accueil puis des personnes qui en
réalité cherchent à détourner chercheurs
en réalité à contourner nous réglait
quelqu'un qui parle et comprend france
n'est pas un combattant mais ces
exercices et là précisément je me suis
moi aussi rendu à deux reprises une fois
ya dix ans bien longtemps dans le
calaisis
et puis une fois il ya quelques il ya
quelques mois encore et bon comme vous
sans sans caméra avec le directeur
départemental de la de la police aux
frontières
vous avez là bas effectivement
s'attendre de vrais réfugiés politiques
mais vous avez aussi en réalité des
candidats à l'immigration économique
j'avais pas rentrer des albanais vous
avez des kosovars qui sont pas
directement menacées dans leur pays les
kosovars par exemple je le rappelle
cette donnée on a des soldats français
qui sont allés mourir au kosovo pour
que le kosovo puisse devenir un état
démocratique donc il faut effectivement
dit c'est renée faut pas tout mélanger
et dans ce million de personnes qui sont
entrées sur le continent européen en
2015 1 million 800 mille entrées
régulières selon l' agence frontex
comme il ya des doubles contient
également un million un million deux
cent mille personnes qui sont entrées en
europe en 2015
vous avez effectivement des vrais
réfugiés politiques mais vous avez aussi
des personnes qui ne sont pas des
réfugiés et qui ont vocation à regagner
leur pays d'origine si on y parvient et
il faudra bien y parvenir parce qu'on
peut pas non plus organisée je voudrais
m'arrêter là on peut pas organiser je
crois que quelqu'un de raisonnable comme
monsieur gorge d'accord on peut pas
organiser le transfert d'une partie
entière de la population du proche
orient vers le continent européen à ça
n'aurait pas de sens oui alors je crois
effectivement il faut bien sérier les
sujets il faut faire aussi attention
vous l'avais dit au début on parle
d'êtres humains avant tout avant de
parler de réfugiés et de migrants
économiques on parle d'êtres humains
c'est toujours compliqué par rapport à
ces situations d'apporter les réponses
adaptées parce que le droit n'apporte
pas toutes les réponses quand on est
face à une détresse humaine évidemment
avant de classer les personnes ont été
amenées à leur porter secours à se
demander quel avenir on peut au minimum
le rassurés dans les premières semaines
sur l'or sont et sur les situations de
leurs enfants et c'est sur calais par
exemple on a effectivement des personnes
qui sont issus de territoires en guerre
et pour lequel le statut de réfugié
s'imposera d'ailleurs le nombre de
demandes d'asile a augmenté en france de
mère de retrait modeste par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé ailleurs guillaume
larrivé a cité le chiffre d'un million
deux personnes rentrées sur le
territoire européen de manière
irrégulière dans le cas de ces
événements très peu ont choisi de
s'installer en france
ceux qui sont à calais sont une partie
de ces gens mais aussi un centre de
personnes qui souhaitent se rendre en
grande-bretagne pour des raisons
économiques c'est évident et le problème
auquel nous nous confrontons à calais
pour quelques milliers de personnes mais
c'est une situation de détresse comme
jeux ludiques et un suisse absolument
c'est les personnes qui souhaitent
rentrer en grande bretagne qui le
peuvent pas et qui ne peuvent pas parce
que la grande bretagne ne veut pas les
accepter parce que nous avons nous
signer des accords ce que je regrette en
2004 qui font que finalement c'est nous
cassions la garde de la frontière du
royaume uni ce que toi mais un peu
paradoxal donc nous avons une
responsabilité indirecte mais donc ça
sert à rien démanteler la jungle de
calais si les accords du pirée résultat
ça va continuer
guillaume larrivé c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui avait signé les accords du touquet
ma bulle ça a été fait en 2003 et en
2004 et a eu pour conséquence de ces
années qui sont désormais assez ancien
une évolution très favorable de la
situation très concrètement dans ce cas
me rappelais pas pour faire la polémique
une donnée objective en 2012 lorsque la
sarkozy françois fillon alain juppé
quitte le pouvoir
il ya dans le calaisis et un peu à côté
côté de dunkerque la grande synthe tout
ça il ya à peu près mille clandestins et
ou demandeur d'asile
il ya à peu près 1000 personnes ok donc
dans cette zone aujourd'hui on est à
6000 7000 8000 9000 ça dépend d'un petit
peu des jours et des évaluations dont on
voit bien qu'il ya une explosion du
phénomène pourquoi parce que depuis il
ya eu la déstabilisation de la de la
syrie il ya eu ce phénomène est commun
rendre et c'est passé les gens qu'ils
common bienvenue de la chancelière
allemande en 2015 qui a été quand même
assez déraisonnable par son caractère
improvisé
je me suis rendu à bernard il ya un an
pour aller voir l'accès des who et avoir
un échange avec le parti de centre-droit
allemand pour pour comprendre pourquoi
il avait fait ça si vite
bon et ils l'ont fait aussi pour des
questions économiques je pense dans leur
situation pour des questions
démographiques mais on en paye un peu
les pots cassés parce que tout ça n'a
pas été réglée voudrait introduire une
autre idée une idée nouvelle
mais extrêmement importante c'est qui
s'est passé des choses en france hélas
en 2015 on a eu 2 138 morts à cause du
terrorisme islamiste
en disant cela je ne dis pas du tout je
ne dis pas du tout immigration égale
automatiquement à sécurité mais je dis
que et je le dis comme vice-président de
la commission denquête antiterrorisme de
l'assemblée nationale nous savons que
parmi les auteurs des attentats de
novembre 2015 en france on a un certain
nombre d'individus qui s'est introduit
en se faisant passer pour des réfugiés
est donc là encore est donc là encore
mon obsession notre obsession à nous ce
doit être le discernement on ne peut pas
accueillir des personnes dont on n'a pas
vérifié l'identité dont on n'a pas
vérifié le profil en termes de sécurité
est un des gros problème qu'on a c'est
qu'en grèce
les fameux hot spot tout cela il n'y a
pas de contrôles policiers effectif est
quand je vous disais vous disais on le
laisse entendre quand même qu'un rapport
entre milan et des terroristes
moi je me réjouis que nous ayons un
débat très policé mais malheureusement
ce qui a pu se passer au cours de ces
derniers mois et ce qui explique pour
une part aussi les réactions de nos
concitoyens c'est qu'on a tenté de
procéder à une assimilation très forte
entre l'idée que ces réfugiés pourraient
représenter une menace pour notre
sécurité ça pu être le cas dans des
situations très particulier a essayé
effectivement fait qu'ils sont entrés
dans des conditions d'europe qui n'ont
pas pu être vérifiées mais là j'ai juste
une remarque je vous en prie bernard
cazeneuve le miso l'intérieur recevait
un certain nombre de députés et de
sénateurs d'ailleurs des commissions des
lois il ya quelques mois
il nous expliquait c'est une donnée
publique que il ya une véritable usine à
faux papiers à vrais faux passeports en
syrie bien voilà on à ce sujet quand
même c'est pas ça c'est un sujet
fantasmatique
on a une introduction dans ces flux de
deux personnes qui n'ont pas d'intention
heureuse et donc on a le devoir encore
une fois de discerner il s'agit pas
d'actes similaires du monde la pâte et
sa gueule d'ange et terrorisme et il y
en a par mu mais bon si vous en tirer la
conclusion puisqu'il ya un risque
potentiel de terrorisme parmi les
réfugiés il faut donc que de l'ensemble
des réfugiés qui tentent de se retrouver
sur le territoire français soit interné
c'est ce que propose sarkozy une
certaine manière s'ils ont une fiche e s
il faut donc considérer que chaque
réfugié et potentiellement intéressante
on n'en est pas sûr si on rentre dans
cette logique
jeudi soir les nox qu'on laisse répondre
mais non mais non je n'écris pas du tout
le monde que je concrètement garmisch
corse à une bombe traitement
concrètement je ne veux pas qu'une
personne arrive en france sans avoir eu
un entretien avec des agents d'europol
ou de tel ou tel organisme de deux
polices européennes ou nationales
je veux pas qu'une personne en ce sens
qu'il vérification sans qu'ils aient une
vérification des empreintes et
l'interrogation des différents fichiers
de police et tout ça vous le savez
peut-être quelqu'un de sérieux ça n'a
pas empêché les trois quarts des
personnes qui sont entrées en france et
en europe
2015 n'ont pas subi ce contrôle policier
est alors parce que le problème tout de
même il faut peut-être dire les choses
de manière plus claire ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières semaines lorsque
notamment le gouvernement a annoncé le
démantèlement de calais c'est que un
ensemble de vos amis il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont peut-être vous
même je n'ai pas épluché vos
déclarations mais ressemble de vous et
millions dit on va répartir c'est la
formule timide et des décalés on va
répartir en réalité des gens qui
correspondent à un danger pour les
français sur le son du territoire
autrement dit ce gouvernement est prêt à
faire n'importe quoi dans ce domaine et
à mettre en danger la sécurité et
lorsqu'on laisse aussi évidemment la
question de sécurité et terrorisme à la
présence de ces réfugiés aux immigrants
conforte naturellement cette idée je ne
veux pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de risque
mais le risque est peut être traité
d'autres manières sans qu'on soit amené
à considérer que l'ensemble de ces
personnes doivent être placés sous une
surveillance continue parce que gros
fond c'est ce que vous dites si un
risque potentiel parmi toutes ces
personnes le risque étant continue
doivent en permanence à trop sous
surveillance c'est une situation qui est
impossible à gérer d'une part et qui ne
permettra pas de résoudre complètement
la menace ne vient pas que de la
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les
attentats on voit évidemment qu'elle a
des origines
cette menace très multiples très
différents ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que ce qui va se passer c'est
pourquoi j'ai été choqué et compris par
vos propos quand vous avez évoqué les
médical est partout en france c'est que
les personnes qu'on va installer dans
ses centres d'accueil d'orientation sur
les vertes qui justement ont fait
l'objet des vérifications de vous parler
parce que ce qui va se passer à quelle
est leur démantèlement
c'est qu'on recense l'ensemble des
personnes qu'on les identifie de manière
plus claire qu'on peut le faire
aujourd'hui que l'ayant fait on les
installe dans des territoires
on les connaît on peut les accompagner
bref on a mis en place des dispositions
qui sont à la fois plus sûr au et plus
sûr pour les populations en laissant
entendre qu'on aurait dit médical et on
laisse penser qu'on va installer des
bidonvilles à la porte de chaque petit
village dans le cas d'un centre
d'accueil va être mis en place et que
dans ce bidonville vont vivre des gens
dont la seule idée sera de rejoindre des
forces armées qu'ils ont précisément
essayé de fuir pour la très grande
majorité d'entre eux doit faire
attention quand on est solidaire des
remarques très concrète premièrement
j'observe que dans ces centres d'accueil
dans nos villages il ya quasiment pas de
famille ya des jeunes hommes
célibataires
c'est une donnée objective qui quand
même m'interroge j'ai 39 ans alors je
constate que ce sont pas des familles
qui qui qui pour la plupart ont fui ce
sont des jeunes hommes célibataires et
pardon de dire aussi directement
le devoir de tout citoyen c'est aussi
sur place sur le terrain de mener le
combat pour la démocratie pour la
liberté
je dis ça avec eux une certaine
solennité mais quand même ce sont pas
des familles se sont pas des jeunes
enfants se sont pas des femmes qui ont
été accueillis par exemple à
saint-bris-le-vineux appoigny à sens
dans les divers centres d'accueil
organisée par le préfet de calvi gueule
parce que souvent sont partis parce que
j'aime ce stade ça france il ya pas
grand monde en réalité par rapport aux
flux et aux images qu'on a vu des gens
qui ont pris la route des balkans et on
pourrait être encore plus clair moi
j'aurais été tout de suite mais je crois
qu'en france j'aurais été tout à fait
favorable à ce que si le conseil
municipal de tel ou tel village y est
favorable si si si c'est bien préparée
avec des associations
on accueille on n'a que quelques
familles ce que je constate c'est que ce
sont des jeunes hommes de 25 28 30 ans
isolé qui ont été transférés du calaisis
vélo vers nos campagnes lorsque je
constate aussi on sait que beaucoup
d'entre eux sont immédiatement en outre
est rapidement reparti donc tout ça n'a
objectivement quasiment aucun sens c'est
une distension voulait rien je
m'interroge sur la définition vous en ai
d'abord on sait qu'à beaucoup de
familles qui sont concernées il suffit
d'observer ce qui se passe
malheureusement dans a traversé la
méditerranée et les milliers de cadavres
malheureusement que les forces
européennes et les bateaux des ambitions
militaires sont md à ramasser avec
malheureusement beaucoup d'enfants en
france effectivement moins de familles
pas mal de célibataire mais vous les
définissez de cette manière c'est à
black des célibataires constitue
naturellement un danger danger pourquoi
un danger pour qui lorsque le fait que
vous insistiez sur ce fait on sont
célibataires sont pas des familles se
veut donc dire que parce que ce sont des
jeunes célibataires qui ont quitté leur
pays dans les conditions qu'on connaît
peut-être vous êtes vous faire raconter
comme je lé fais faire un sombre de
migrants et réfugiés leur histoire par
où ils sont passés pour en arriver là
dans un centre de rétention j'avais des
accords auxquels vous avez vécu et
pourquoi est ce que le fait d'être des
célibataires les képis cocktail
constituerait un problème particulier
j'ai préco mixer les questions mais je
vous réponds à proximité les écoles mais
j'ai entendu plein de gens qui sont des
normes extrêmement
la question que je pose la question je
me pose vous êtes un jeune homme de 30
ans vous avez une compagne parfois vous
avez des enfants vous êtes dans un pays
qui est frappée par la guerre qu'est ce
que vous faites ce que je constate c'est
que ils ont décidé de partir et qu'ils
ont beaucoup d'entre eux laissé leur
compagne et leurs enfants sur place
moi parlons ça m'interroge et ça me gêne
et je pense qu'il faudrait effectivement
qu'on évolue beaucoup parce que parce
que ce que j'aimerais également au
casting de choc ils vont pas du tout je
vous jure constat je lui envoie
effectivement plus tôt j'ai entendu du
toit siona les déplaire siens que ce
grave si ses hommes
ce que je voudrais guette en corse
c'est con des cassures peut-être un peu
le la situation actuelle et qu'on essaie
d'organiser les choses mais la
différence
plutôt que de constater que ces
personnes par dizaines de milliers
traversent la méditerranée avec
effectivement des cadavres avec une
espèce de scandale absolu humanitaire
une véritable tragédie
je préférerais qu'on organise les choses
différemment qu'avec notamment l' agence
des nations-unies pour la protection des
réfugiés
on est d'aider des lieux d'orientation
de transit dans des pays tiers
la situation il faut organiser les
choses de manière très différente
aujourd'hui c'est un scandale c'est un
scandale humanitaire
c'est un scandale naturellement pour ces
personnes et c'est aussi un manque de
respect pour beaucoup de français qui ne
comprennent pas cette situation nous
amène à la suite parce qu'effectivement
je le disais en ouverture gaëtan gorce
vous avez au sénat travailler sur un
rapport avec jacques legendre rapport
titré l'europe au défi des migrants agir
vraiment donc vous allez nous dire si
vous considérez que la vraie vie
l'europe mais effectivement cessé
je rebondis tout de suite je fais le
lien avec ce que vous disiez guillaume
larrivé c'est vous fait cette
proposition de centre qui gérerait
l'arrivée des gens dans leur pays qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
gaëtan gorce est ce que ce serait une
bonne idée sachant qu'il y a quand même
déjà des millions de gens qui ont fui
leur pays qui sont en turquie qui sont
en jordanie et picard aussi toute une
part de gens qui viennent en france qui
viennent pas forcément de ces pays en
guerre donc est ce que c'est
votre point de vue ça peut lancer notre
discussion sur la dimension
supranationale de ce sujet oui je crois
qu'il faut effectivement tenter de
réfléchir aux solutions sur les
problèmes qui sont à venir même s'il
faut éviter effectivement d'exploiter de
manière parfois un peu odieuse la
situation que nous connaissons de
raconter la crise migratoire qu'on vient
d'affronter et qui peut-être d'ailleurs
au bondir on voit bien que la situation
en syrie ne s'améliore pas en irak
cette crise a révélé deux choses la
première c'est la faiblesse des
dispositifs dont nous pouvons disposer
face et les mouvements de cette
importance la réflexion a été engagée
sur schengen elle a été engagée sur les
règles relatives à l'asile elle était
engagée sur le rôle d'une police
extérieur qui pourraient venir en
renfort des polices nationales aux
frontières de schengen c'est notamment
frontex
toutes ces questions ont été soulevées
elle a aussi montré une deuxième chose
c'est que nous étions à travers cette
crise migratoire confronté à un
mouvement en population réguliers dont
la crise a été une belle des manières la
cnps et c'est là que ça monte évidemment
un niveau extrêmement important on était
en moyenne à 200 milles irrégulier par
an auparavant la crise on a été à plus
d'un million d'années et proches année
on sera sur des chiffres relativement
important cette année même si évidemment
un tarissement du mouvement depuis
l'accord avec la turquie
ça a révélé que nous étions
effectivement confrontés à une évolution
régulière des mouvements de populations
auxquelles il faut réfléchir et le
constat que nous avons fait dans ce
rapport c'est que à la fois les outils
existants ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure schengen excellent et est
aujourd'hui un peu inadapté et qu'il
fallait faire évoluer mes coaches
surtout nous avions mené une réflexion
et définir une stratégie à l'échelle
européenne pour construire avec les pays
d'origine des politiques qui permettent
à la fois d'organiser le développement
de ces pays et des solutions économiques
qui sont aujourd hui très loin d'être
envisageable à court terme pour ces
territoires avec une croissance
démographique importante est au
contraire une situation économique qui
reste extrêmement difficile
et puis pour organiser aussi pour une
part l'accueil de ces populations dans
des conditions qui soient organisées cia
qui n'oblige pas à passer par les
circuits les trafics l'on connaît
aujourd'hui et qui met en danger on est
arrivés par les mairies hotspot c'est à
dire les points d'arrivée des gens qui
fuit leur pays c'est quelque chose
différente
cm-cic autre chance il ya deux choses
différentes les hotspots c'est dans la
perspective de la crise que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui via la syrie
d'une certaine manière il existe
aujourd'hui un peu en turquie à un
travail commence à se faire même s'il
est très modeste en turquie dans les
cons et vis-à-vis de la population
syrienne réfugiés en turquie pour
organiser
leur arrivée à travers une sélection
mise en place avec le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés en turquie par exemple ça
se fait aussi en liban et en janvier la
france avait cueilli des personnes peu
nombreuses mais accueilli des personnes
moi c'est du haut niveau et et
d'aujourd'hui non là encore vous avez
raison d'en relativiser parce que ce
dont on parle en france aujourd'hui
c'est 6 à 7000 personnes officiellement
arrivé peut-être le double si on prend
en compte les gens qui sont entrés de
manière régulière on est quand même sur
des nombres de personnes extrêmement
modestes donc ça les hotspots ça peut
être très utile je crois dans le cadre
de l'accord qui en tant que ces crevures
militerait une fois que la crise
syrienne sera fini ça va continuer il
faut réfléchir une maîtrise ça va
continuer dans des proportions qui
restent quand même relativement modestes
rappelle quand même que les mouvements
migratoires dans le monde
ces 3 % la population mondiale c'était 5
% au début du 20e siècle les mouvements
migratoires était plus important qu'ils
le sont aujourd'hui
ils vont évidemment vers l'europe ils
vont vers les etats unis ils vont aussi
en afrique dans le cadre de circuits
régionaux c'est vrai ou si on existe un
mouvement mondial
l'europe n'est pas la seule concernée
même si effectivement apporte une partie
importante de ce mouvement vient vers
leur dos on doit avoir une réserve
stratégique parce que se barricader
n'apportera pas de solution il y aura
toujours un trou dans la cuirasse
il faut donc effectivement avoir là je
suis d'accord guillaume larrivé des
dispositifs de protection qui soit bien
organisé qui fasse que la loi soit
respectée c'est essentiel mais derrière
il faut mettre en place des dispositifs
qui nous permet de développer une
coopération entre états d'origine où ils
trouvent un intérêt aussi à nous
accompagner parce qu'il ya un chiffre et
je m'arrête là dessus qu'il faut avoir
en tête ce qui explique aussi pourquoi
les états d'origine n'ont pas forcément
intérêt à nous aider à limiter les flux
migratoires c'est que l'aide au
développement c'est trois fois moins que
ce que rapporte le revenu renvoyé par
les travailleurs migrants depuis les
pays où ils sont installés
tant qu'on aura cet écart de 1 à 3 vous
comprendrez bien que des pays qui sont
des pays pauvres ont plutôt intérêt à
voir des ressortissants qui vont en
europe aux etats-unis et ailleurs et qui
transfère ensuite une partie de leurs
économies vers leur pays d'origine
qu'une et de développement qui reste
extrêmement faible
il est arrivé il va dans votre sens qu
est à voir sur ce qui est un peu
désespérant
je le dis très directement c'est que ce
que vient de dire gaëtan gorce et plein
de bon sens ça fait à peu près dix ans
qu'on dit en 2008 l'union européenne
était précédée par la france je prends
ma part de la chaux j'étais directeur de
cabinet adjoint des mises de
l'immigration on a négocié
on a négocié un pacte européen sur
l'immigration et l'asile signé par les
27 autres pays européens qui disait déjà
ça tous les principes y était j'ai relu
le pacte européen
celle ci après dix ans maintenant on
disait ça déjà accueil d'une immigration
légale organisé lutte contre les
clandestins dialogue avec les pays
d'origine co-développement et et l'union
européenne n'est pas passée du pacte aux
actes et voilà on est engagé dans la vie
publique pour faire bouger sur le faire
parce que jeune homme il n'y a pas une
unité d'enquêté sur le sujet la période
quand je crois vraiment que l'union
européenne s'est enfermé ces dernières
années dans une sorte de routine
bureaucratique que des vrais choix n'ont
pas été faits voilà on est tombé dans la
gestion de procédures ya pas eu de
volonté politique ya peu une impulsion
le système schengen et c'est bien triste
en réalité est en état de mort clinique
ça ça fonctionne plus est ce qu'il
faudra faire dans les mois qui viennent
lorsque et la france et l'allemagne
or ont renouvelé leur leur gouvernement
c'est je crois vraiment entrer dans le
dans le concret initiatives concrètes
pour moi j'aimerais que le gouvernement
français et le gouvernement allemand
gèrent ensemble leur politique de
coopération vis-à-vis des pays d'origine
qu'ensemble on passe un accord avec les
pays d'origine très concret disant voilà
sur l'aide au développement vous finance
à l'université on vous finance tel
hôpital et on prendra x ou y
personne pour venir étudier en europe
bref qu'on organise les choses de
manière un peu de paresse qu'on ait de
façon simple on est on est dans les
discours on n'est pas dans l'action au
plan européen et au plan national sur
ces questions il ya beaucoup de bonnes
intentions il ya quand même beaucoup
d'argent vie par l'europe en ce moment
sur l'accueil sur les opérations en
méditerranée
- essayé des réglages c'est le problème
d'une certaine manière et c'est ce que
dit guillaume larrivé même si on
pourrait nuancer son propos c'est que
effectivement la volonté politique fait
défaut
tous les arguments que j'ai développée
là d'ailleurs le rapport s'appelle agir
vraiment voilà l'europe a mis sur la
verite vous demandez pourquoi pourquoi
pas
l'europe a mis sur la table tous les
éléments les éléments contraignants les
éléments d'intervention humanitaire les
éléments financiers l'évolution des
réglementations
le problème c'est qu'elle se heurte à
des états parce que l'europe ait une
volonté qui est fait uniquement de
l'addition de la volonté des états
membres il sortait les états qui pour
une part de veulent pas avancer dans ces
domaines on fait beaucoup la critique de
l'allemagne pour une part je pourrais la
faire sur le terrain économique je la
ferai moins sur ce terrain là parce que
pour le coup l'allemagne après les
initiatives a fait bouger les lignes
notamment à travers l'accord oeil
turquie aurait angela merkel le paye à
chaque élection depuis
oui mais elle la porte imaginez imaginez
simplement que madame merkel n'est pas
fait ce qu'elle a fait l'an passé que
devenait le million de réfugiés dont on
parle ou serait-il aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on les aurait parquet dans les
balkans dans des conditions les états
qui sont sa des balcons voulait les
accueillir au soudan par les accueillir
le problème auquel on est confronté dès
lors et cela c'est qu'une partie de
l'europe et notamment la partie la plus
à l'est de l'europe refusent de coopérer
de manière active
or on ne peut pas aujourd'hui les c'est
parce que c'est une chose aussi qu'on ne
dit pas on peut pas jouer laisser les
états les premiers états d'accueil en
parfait la grèce et l'italie dans la
situation ces états sont placés on vous
entendez la musique elle nous dit que
c'est la fin des missions à des lèvres
un débat qui pourrait voilà qui aurait
pu être qui pourrait être plus long sur
le sujet merci à tous les deux d'être
venus débattre sur notre plateau merci à
vous tous chez vous d'avoir parfois
exprimées vigoureusement vos positions
sur ce sujet resté avec nous pour le
flash de midi puis la deuxième partie
dimension politique ce sera aujourd'hui
avec stéphane le foll minizoo
l'agriculture porte parole du
gouvernement
il sera interrogé par francis letellier
au revoir merci à tous les deux et
bondues